I would have my own special on TLC if I
ate these for breakfast every day hey
guys I'm Brendon my TV producer and
today we will be comparing classic
buttermilk American pancakes against the
Japanese kind and of course I'm gonna be
taking care of the American version
because I am Colombian and I'm just
super curious about what makes a classic
yummy buttermilk American pinkie and I'm
Alvin I'm gonna tasty producer and I'll
be making the japanese-style pancakes I
think they're really really cool play on
regular pancakes because they're so
different and they're like really fluffy
so let's get to it all right so let's
get started with this american pancakes
so as a colombian you know i have been
very intrigued about a lot of things
that compose the american culture
some of those include classic recipes
like pancakes why are people so obsessed
with things so I was really happy to
realize that the recipes please
straightforward you just need your flour
your soul sugar everything else and of
course what makes the buttermilk
pancakes buttermilk I guess that makes
sense
[Music]
so nothing crazy you just add all your
ingredients to a bowl and stir and stir
until you get that fluid batter that
smells like heaven and says that
everything's gonna be okay and then you
proceed to the pan
oh it's some sexy batter right there
just love the way batter it falls in any
any freakin way so once you get all
those little bubbles then you're ready
to flip and this is where you actually
need some skills which I don't have oh
my geez what the hell happened I tried
over there Brenda it was a stubborn
pancake I tried my best
yikes Wow yeah let me just hide the bed
work as long as you have that one
pancake that looks seasoned you can
cover up you can cover it up and this
swatter guy right here I have the cover
of them exactly it's so real my face
wouldn't have makeup some makeup they're
not that tall but that's okay which
means they're pretty chewy and they're
gonna be nice and dense which I think
look at that syrup though that's a nice
pour oh thank you that was unintentional
but you have to give me credit on my
cuttings oh do your cutting skills are
perfect it's like Gordon round
[Music]
right now that Brenda's done that I'm
gonna go ahead and make the
japanese-style pancakes a couple months
ago I was actually in Japan one of the
most memorable things that I ate there
was these japanese-style pancakes that
we had ones they were so mind-blowing
Lee cool it came to your table and there
was this big puffy fluffy pancake and so
I was like man like I need to figure out
how to make this into a tasty video I'll
give those clouds super super soft so a
smooth
folding gentle motion will enable you to
mix together the pancake mix and egg
whites without breaking the bubbles if
you're using a nonstick pan which you
should you don't need to grease the pan
or the molds the reason why is that if
you do use grease on your pan any spots
that have the oil will actually Brown a
lot faster than the spots that don't so
when you flip the pancake over you're
gonna end up with a spotted look versus
a really really satisfying smooth light
brown color which is what we want that
color is insane feel like a tiny person
is gonna come out of one of those
pancakes what the penny stripper just
jumps out why is it a stripper
these pancakes aren't actually eaten for
breakfast there it's served as more of
like a dessert when you eat them it's
usually with a bunch of friends you're
studying you're socializing it's kind of
what they do in Japan they just take
everything that we do and make it
perfect I mean these are really fun they
have like obviously an allure about them
cute looks like Sunday morning pancakes
roll out of bed you might be a little
hungover from Saturday night
that's the pancakes you want to eat in
the morning I think the the texture is
actually a real winner with the Japanese
pancake I would pick the buttermilk
pancakes this is classic all-american
delicious dishes be honest I won't have
any issue being honest I will tell you
that right now
okay Oh God all right so you're ready
yeah here it is man I made this with all
my heart I made this with a couple of
eggs and some flour all right it's going
here get it all drizzle it all over
there that golden beauty I like the
cinnamon
I like the density very different good
yours aren't pretty freakin good
compared to regular pancakes more of a
cake texture which doesn't diminish it
is I think that it's still pretty good
it's just a different texture
let's switch and compared to our own
version there's yours
[Music]
I see what you're saying this is
definitely dead it's like different but
it's good this one is definitely more
like cake yes it was all the egg whites
and the egg yolks you know give it
richness and egg whites could make it
fluffier the flavors of fours are very
different the textures are different if
you know how to make regular pancakes
you want to try something new and you
want to give yourself a project you want
to take a pretty picture for Instagram
you know it's like pretty cool I'd say
go for this but like we're just looking
for something really great to eat it's
delicious it's homemade I would say go
for those it's easy
down-to-earth but if you want out just
don't burn it like Brenda did and then
you'll be great I'll see that do you
really Oh would you look at that what
what prove it